aller en france nouvelle audience
aujourd'hui pour le ministre des pme
devant la justice via la grise est et
bien va devoir s'expliquer sur sa
situation patrimoniale devant la haute
autorité à la transparence à la vie
publique a selon elle la déclaration du
ministre serait incomplète ou mensongère
c'est la première fois qu'un ministre en
exercice doit être jugé par un tribunal
correctionnel pour plus d'explications
va tout de suite retrouvé notre reporter
à glee marosi devant le tribunal
correctionnel de paris
[Musique]
bonjour gilmore vous êtes donc devant le
tribunal correctionnel de paris au doigt
finalement comparaître le ministre
aujourd'hui
oui tout à fait ma gallien finalement
vous l'avez dit parce que là ce procès
avait déjà été renvoyé le 22 septembre
dernier le ministre n'avait tout
simplement pas pu se libérer un problème
d'agenda selon son avocat alors agent
d'administrer l'expression est bien
connu mais ce renvoi avait tout de même
un petit peu étonné et agacé le
ministère public écoutez le procureur à
l'époque
tout le monde a un calendrier personne
ne méconnaît l'existence d'un agenda de
ministre alors de deux choses l'une soit
on ne juge pas les ministres soit on
considère qu'ils doivent répondre comme
tous les autres justiciables voilà le
ton est donné alors on espère que cette
fois ci alain griset se rendre à sa
convocation donc réponse aujourd'hui à
13h30 et sur le fond du dossier
guillemin et qu'est ce qui est reproché
au ministre dm
et bien dans les faits très exactement
olivier le ministre est cité à
comparaître pour déclarations
mensongères ou incomplet de sa situation
patrimoniale alain griset aurait omis de
déclarer un peu plus de 170 mille euros
de participation financière l'on ne va
pas rentrer dans les détails techniques
de ce dossier pour faire simple cet
argent le ministre explique que c'est
une organisation interprofessionnelle
qui le lui aurait remis organisation
dont il était président en 2019 pour le
faire fructifier
or selon la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique et bien
cette opération n'était pas légale
écoutez
monsieur grise est à dix à la haute
autorité qu'il avait l'accord de la
cnams pour qu'il puisse faire fructifier
cette somme mais alors on est dans la
confusion des patrimoines ce qui n'est
pas conforme à la loi cette omission
avait pour but d'empêcher la révélation
de faits susceptibles de recevoir la
qualification pénale d'abus de confiance
abus de confiance et donc la piste qui
est également suivi par tracfin la
cellule anti blanchiment de bercy qui
donc poursuit son enquête contre les
mini dans ce dossier alors on imagine
bien qu alain griset se dit innocent
d'ailleurs il est toujours en fonction
au gouvernement guillemin
et oui tout à fait un magali c'est
d'ailleurs de ce fait le premier
ministre à vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure le premier ministre en exercice
à être jugé par un tribunal
correctionnel alors alain griset avait
refusé au printemps dernier de
comparaître sur reconnaissance préalable
de culpabilité c'est un petit peu le
plaider coupable de la française ainsi
si vous voulez cela alain griset l'avait
ne l'avait pas accepté et du côté des
arguments et bien pour son avocat la
défense est simple le ministre n'avait
pas à déclarer des sommes qui ne lui
appartenait pas écoutez monsieur grise
et était totalement de bonne foi dans
cette histoire tout s'est fait en toute
transparence
la somme apparaissait comme appartenant
à la confédération
nous contestons que cette somme faisait
partie du patrimoine de monsieur crise
et c'est d'ailleurs pour cela qu'il ne
l'a pas déclaré alors le ministre des
pme comptent bien sur cette convocation
pour s'expliquer mais même en cas de
condamnation il veut rester au
gouvernement je continuerai tant que le
président me fait confiance avait-il
déclaré en septembre dernier il faut
dire qu alain griset n'est pas le seul
membre du gouvernement à être dans une
posture un peu délicate selon la sp ce
sont une demi-douzaine c'est une demi
douzaine de personnalités de l'exécutif
qui aurait maille à partir avec la
justice merci beaucoup guillemin pour
toutes ces précisions guillemin rosie en
direct devant le tribunal correctionnel
de paris